[Music]
[Applause]
he's our good buddy he's the Monday
Morning Quarterback he's Albert Breer
joins us on the program
help me understand what's going on with
Baltimore with Greg Roman stepping down
I don't know if that means you're fired
you part ways mutually but what's this
mean for Lamar Jackson's future there
you know I don't know it means a whole
lot on Lamar Jackson's future because
that contract situation is so
complicated Dan
um I do think it shows a sign that they
want it is a sign that they want to push
their offense forward and we're Greg
Roman I think did a lot in building the
right sort of offense for Lamar Jackson
coming out of college
um the same way he built an offense for
Colin Kaepernick in San Francisco I
think now the feeling is we need to move
the passing game to another level and
you know that is probably what
necessitated some staff changes and so
um you know look it's not all Greg's
fault like you know they they lose
Rashad Bateman for the year who's shown
a ton of promises their first round pick
from 2021
um and the cupboard certainly wasn't
full at receiver with with Hollywood
Brown having been traded before the
season two
um so like I I don't think it's all on
Greg but I do think it's an
acknowledgment that they have to push
the offense forward which I think would
appeal to Lamar but again like the the
complicate the contract situation itself
is so complicated that I just I don't
see that this solves or ruins anything
if that makes sense but if Lamar Jackson
said here's the deal 230 million dollars
guaranteed and I'm going to sign this
contract yeah can it be that simple
sure the Ravens aren't doing that right
now you know what I mean like I mean I
think the Divide here is
um is what you think it is which is the
Ravens are willing to go to the top of
the quarterback Market but they want to
do it on a more traditional quarterback
contract whereas Lamar wants a fully
guaranteed deal and look it's full it's
really easy to understand from Lamar's
perspective if you think about it he's
just put his body on the line for five
years in an unprecedented way for a
quarterback and if you're him and you've
gone through that and you finished the
last two years injured
if your team says well we want you to
mitigate our injury risk three years
from now by making the last couple of
years of a new deal no I'm guaranteed
what are you going to say to them you're
probably going to look at them sideways
you know so
um you know at the same time you know
you can understand why the Ravens would
want to mitigate their list because the
first three years in the league you can
look at Lamar and say it's risky to play
in that way but he wasn't getting hurt
now he is getting hurt he's finished the
last two years injured so because of
that and all of that it's you know a
complicated situation and I don't know
that there's an easy fix here I do think
there's going to be a tell though when
we get to that period where the
franchise tags are issued which is the
end of February beginning of March right
around the combine the Ravens are gonna
have to make a decision on whether or
not to put the non-exclusive tag on them
or the exclusive tag exclusive tag is
going to cost about 45 million dollars
the non-exclusive tax about 30 million
they put the exclusive tag on them at
that higher number they're effectively
taking them off the market so no one
else can talk talk to him and at that
point it behooves them to get a
long-term deal done because they want to
lower that cap number if they put the
non-exclusive tag on them things get a
lot more interesting because then other
teams can't it's not just that other
teams can talk to them other teams at
that point can sign them to an offer
sheet and have them for two first round
picks so I invest the next real
checkpoint this whole Saga
Byron Leftwich getting fired in Tampa
more likely or less likely that Tom
Brady would go back or does this not
have any impact whatsoever on Brady I
don't think it's likely Brady goes back
there but it makes it more likely I
would say I do think there are some
things about what the way the offense
worked this year
um you know that frustrated Tom Brady
and you know part of it is again
Personnel you know you lose Ryan Jensen
for the year you lose Alex Kappa and
free agency Ali marpet retires
um you know their tackles got banged up
over the course of the year there's no
question that personnel has something to
do with it but
um I I don't know that you know Tom
Brady believes in Byron left which the
same way he believed in Josh McDaniels
the same way he believed in Billy
O'Brien and so I do think you know
hearing Rick Stroud say Billy O'Brien
would be a candidate to be the next
offensive coordinator in Todd Bulls I
think I think Rick said that last week I
mean that's a carrot for Tom Brady you
know so I think which way they go with
their offensive coordinator higher will
probably be a pretty good indication of
how realistic they think bringing Tom
Brady's is back but I think of Brady's
playing in 2023 in all likelihood
somewhere else help me understand the
Raiders logic that you say goodbye to
Derek Carr in front of everybody now
you're open for business at that
position normally if you do something
like that you have an idea who you're
bringing in yep right
they have options though that's the
thing is they've got two guys who've got
an extensive background in their system
and Tom Brady and Jimmy Garoppolo who
both those guys have a freeway to free
agency right now you know what I mean
like those guys like there's no
franchise tags there's no there's
nothing to stop those guys from getting
to the market and Josh McDaniels has a
relationship with both of those guys and
so you know I think you have a pretty
good idea that there's going to be an
option out there for you and you know I
I know I've used this example with you
before Dan but it's sort of the Alex
Smith in Kansas City
um situation you know where I think when
they signed Derek Carter that contract
the logic behind it was if we're going
to turn them into our Alex Smith and
that would be that that would mean he's
sort of your long-term bridge where he's
going to be your quarterback for the
next few years you can be competitive
with them in there you can build around
them you can continue to construct a
roster that can support a Young
quarterback and then when you find
somebody who thinks really special
you can strike and then trade the
veteran away
I just think they looked at Derek Carr
and there were you know issues with
toughness issues with competitiveness
issues with getting the most out of the
people around him that they had that
caused them to sort of look around and
seeing those two guys potentially being
out there and now you know absolutely
going to be out there on the market you
say to yourself there's a better
long-term bridge out there for us than
Derek Carr especially the number that
he's gonna that he's commanding right
now he's uh the Monday Morning
Quarterback Albert Brier you can go to
uh Monday morningquarterback.com
Sean Payton more likely to take a job
this year or go back into TV
I sort of think he's going to go back
into TV
um you know I think this is sort of a
day-to-day thing with him uh you know I
talk about all of these openings and and
I mean like here's the thing is like I I
know like two things that are really
important to him our geography and
quarterback right and like I think
staying close to Los Angeles would have
been ideal for him which is why the
Chargers kept coming up because the
Chargers emphatically check both those
boxes
and then you know you hear his comments
which he made publicly about there being
some organizations where you just can't
win right and how the quarterback
affects that and like Arizona and Denver
can he win there you know because like
you look at the quarterback contracts in
those two places and it's it's not like
okay like I'm gonna give this I'm gonna
take this guy out for a test drive for a
year and then get rid of them like those
contracts sort of lock those guys into
those franchises for the next few years
and like Sean Payton at his age might
only have one more shot at this so does
he want to Hitch his future to
Russell Wilson in Denver does he want to
hit his future to Kyler Murray in
Arizona
I'm not sure that he does
and I actually think the Houston
situation might be more interesting yeah
I said that too you know like because
like you get to pick your own
quarterback there and look like part of
it is you're dealing with more unknown
in Houston but
you pick your own quarterback there
you've got two first-round picks in each
of the next two drafts now maybe you
have to give up one of those to get them
but you've still got a lot of them you
know and in Denver or Arizona you'd be
giving them up and then you wouldn't
have much left you know
um you have cap space you have some
young Talent the team was competitive at
the end of the year
like I just look at it like like if I'm
if I'm Sean Payton right now I'm
probably studying Bryce young you know
what I mean like I'm probably looking
pretty hard at Bryce young and saying to
myself
how much do I like this kid because if I
can draft him into Houston now I've got
him on a rookie contract at a fraction
of what I'd be paying Wilson and Denver
or Murray in Arizona and I have him on
that contract for the next few years and
I have all these ticks to build around
him I just think like Houston to me
there's just something that's more
interesting about that situation you
know if I'm Sean Payton and again you're
doing it without the certainty
quarterback which uncertainty on other
parts of the roster which you know like
you're gonna have to get some draft
picks right you're gonna have to get
some free agents right but I think
they're it's an intriguing situation to
sort of build the franchise in your own
image if you want to the other thing is
like you know if you sit and wait and
you decide to go do TV for another year
maybe that charger's job is open in
2024. if you were the Chargers
would you have made that move
you know I really like Brandon Staley as
a as a as a coach I think he's got
potential so
you know I I'm hesitant to say yes the
only reason why is because I do think
when you hire somebody Brandon Staley's
age it like you have to give that guy
some Runway he was only a coordinator
for one year so like all the game
management stuff and everything else
he's still learning it and he's really
really smart and like I think having a
chance to go get the coordinator higher
right remember he wanted to hire Kevin
O'Connell first when he got to the
Chargers and like by the looks of it
that would have been a home run higher
the Rams blocked O'Connell from going so
you give him another chance at getting
that right I think there's a chance that
like Staley could wind up looking like a
home run five years from now the problem
is that Sean Payton's a home run right
now you know what I mean like and Sean
Payton with Justin Herbert really sounds
like it could be a home run right now
and you look at like the construct of
that roster and Justin's young but the
rest of that roster like it's all guys
that are in the middle of prime of their
careers you know like Mike Williams
Keenan Allen Joey Bosa Irwin James like
you're in a championship window right
now so I think that's the question if
I'm the charger if I'm one of the
spanoses like that's my question is like
I really believe in Brandon Staley maybe
and I I you know I I really believe he's
going to grow into something special but
given what I have today right now can I
sell out
what we have right now for you know what
it might for what we might have in five
years if that makes sense
what's the NFL's end game with all these
games in Europe
I think at one point they wanted to put
a team over there
um I had a number of people in the um
like at the executive level in the NFL
office tell me that it was initially a
15-year plan when they started the
international Series in 2007 and so that
would put us right now like right now is
when you'd have a team in London I think
the logistical issues got in the way of
that
um I like I know at one point they even
studied air travel to see if there were
advances coming in air travel that might
alleviate some of the logistical issues
but I just think like the idea of having
like Seattle play in a playoff game in
London in a one-off sort of situation
that they can't plan around yeah was
going to make it too difficult but I
think they want to continue to grow
those markets and Germany and and
England and you know I think the next
couple Frontiers probably Brazil Spain
like I think those are coming
um and the goal really
um Dan is to continue to grow Revenue I
mean that's that's what it is at the end
of the day you know and I think when
when Roger became commissioner there was
this feeling that they had gotten done
growing up like with the construction
League what it was they'd gotten done
growing up so they needed to start
growing out and growing inventory and so
you know that's 17 games that's Thursday
Night Football that's
um putting 14 teams rather than 12 in
the playoffs that's going back to Los
Angeles and adding the two teams and
that ultimately is going International
it's adding inventory to what you
already have
what about Mexico City given the
proximity or you know a team in Canada
yeah I think if the money was there they
would have done it already
um you know it's funny like I think we
all I I think you'd agree with this
Germany is a much better market for
football than the UK right yeah you'd
agree with that like you know there have
actually been like players like Bjorn
Werner and Sebastian Vollmer that have
come there there's the history with the
military bases there Michael Strahan was
born there yeah you know and like how
American football's actually been played
there NFL Europe all the teams were in
Germany the reason they didn't go to
Germany the first the reason they went
to London first is because they thought
there was more money to be made in
London and you know like I whether they
were right or wrong that was always the
feeling and so you know I I think the
group of owners that are you know
running the show now they're about the
bottom line and you know for one reason
or another
they didn't feel like the money there
was enough money to be made in Mexico
City or Toronto to put a team there
full-time otherwise they would have done
it and they did feel like there was
promise for that in London like you put
one or two teams in London and now
you're really growing the pie
I don't think that they felt like adding
a team in Mexico City or Toronto would
grow the pie enough for them to you know
change the math on everything and do all
the things that would be needed to do it
you're upset special this weekend is
now Cincinnati's not an upset is it
okay surprise
I had the Bengals winning
um I'd keep an eye on the Cowboys I I
just
they look like a different team on
Monday night you know and I really
believe in the Niners roster the Niners
coaching staff
like if we get into a critical situation
at the end of the fourth quarter is the
seventh round rookie going to be able to
steer the ship you know so I just
I I look at all the games I think all
the games have potential for upset like
you know but I the the Cowboys are the
team like I I sort of look at them and
did they find something in Tampa you
know and you got all these people
doubting them now and there's Talent on
that roster and Dak feels doubted and
Mike McCarthy feels doubted and they've
been told for three years how
everybody's jobs are on the line I just
there's part of me that wonders like
you know if if they can create a little
Havoc for Brock Purdy early in that game
and they've got the guys to do it with
Micah Parsons and Demarcus Lawrence
could they get that game into the fourth
quarter where maybe you would bet on Dak
Prescott pulling through in the last
five minutes over bro and it comes down
to a field goal by Brett Maher who
missed foreign
Brock Purdy play his way out of being
the starter next year
I think that's going to sort of depend
on opportunity you know um like I think
like if they have the opportunity to
sign Tom Brady do they take it with the
roster that they have you know
um what does Trey lance look like coming
back off the injury you know Jimmy
Garoppolo is not coming back but I'd say
that those are the two like variables
you think the radio is a real
possibility huh you think Brady's a real
possibility in San Francisco I think
that I I think the Niners have left that
door open since deciding not to do it in
2020. so like I don't I think it'd be a
consideration for the Niners I think
they certainly meet on it they certainly
talk about it wow um yeah I think it
would absolutely be on the table I mean
what's great about Purdy you know like
and I think this is what's going to be
so interesting about Purdy is yeah I had
somebody tell me this that you know and
and I know the Niners like this about
him coming out of college was and this
is something you have to do in the NFL
at times
like how many times did Ohio at Iowa
State did he have to be the best player
on the field for them to win you know
like it's different than like a Mac
Jones or a Justin fields or you know
even a Trevor Lawrence like coming out
of their schools like how many times did
Brock party have to be the best player
on the field to win at Iowa State every
weekend if
you have back's ability to maybe level
up and be equal to the circumstances
I think that's what they see in Brock
party right now like I think internally
that's what they see in Broad party
right now and I think that there's real
Intrigue in the idea of building around
him and I don't think it's the worst
idea in the world to look at this and
say maybe we should go into the spring
and throw the doors open and have Brock
Purdy and treylands battle it out let
the best man win yeah well they're cheap
you know with their contracts certainly
uh Purdy is you could bring in Brady for
a year and have pretty be his understudy
there right let those two guys compete
to be the number two number two uh have
a great weekend always great to talk to
you thank you for your time all right
thanks Dan all righty that's the Monday
Morning Quarterback that's Albert Greer